en 2013 julie payette devient directrice
du centre des sciences de montréal
un musée scientifique populaire dans le
vieux port de montréal
une nomination prestigieuse pour la
première canadienne qui s'est rendu dans
l'espace mais aujourd'hui certains ex
employés gardent un souvenir amer de son
passage au centre des sciences un climat
toxique causé par des critiques et
réprimandes injustifiée c'est ce
qu'affirme une ex employée qui dit que
l'attitude de julie payette était la
principale raison de son départ une
autre parle d'intimidation
les gens étaient terrorisés à l'idée de
présenter un projet
c'était fou on se faisait des réunions
pour voir quoi dire comment le dire pour
éviter les crises
une dizaine d'ex employés ont accepté de
témoigner certains parlent d'un climat
de terreur tous ont requis l'anonymat
afin que leur témoignage ne nuise pas à
leur activité professionnelle
c'est histoire comporte des similitudes
avec celle racontée par des membres de
réseaux à la semaine dernière dans un
reportage de la bbc diffusé la semaine
dernière une dizaine d'entre eux
rapporté un climat malsain qui aurait
mené à plusieurs démissions
depuis l'arrivée en poste de julie
payette en 2017
le gouvernement fédéral mène une enquête
sur la situation
situation qui selon nos sources existait
déjà au centre des sciences
je veux appuyer les courageuses personne
de rideau à l' on n'a pas le droit de ne
pas les appuyer
je veux confirmer ce qu'elles disent
certains se porte à la défense de julie
payette
l'une dit qu'elle était aussi exigeante
envers les autres qu envers elle-même
julie payette voulait faire bouger les
choses elle avait envie que le musée
soit sur la carte et qu'on soit une
référence
il fallait que les équipes suivent sinon
ça ne marchait pas julie payette a
quitté le centre des sciences de
montréal en octobre 2016
neuf mois plus tard elle devenait 29e
gouverneur général du canada
un choix du gouvernement de justin
trudeau qui disait à l'époque que cette
nomination avait fait l'objet d'une
vérification rigoureuse des antécédents
de julie payette
aujourd'hui le bureau de la gouverneure
générale dit ne pas vouloir commenter
ces nouvelles allégations de sources
anonymes
l'attaché de presse de julie payette se
porte à sa défense il dit qu'elle n'a
jamais été témoin de quoi que ce soit
qui ressemble de près ou de loin à ce
qui est allégué est dit que julie
payette est une femme exceptionnelle qui
est toujours dédié sa carrière aux
principes de rigueur et de respect ici m
caron radio canada montréal